[Music]
a lot of people see a cat up in a tree
they're just like oh yeah that thing
will get down here in a couple days hey
sweetie how long you been in this tree
but what they don't realize is that
sometimes they don't
i'm shawn sears
and i'm tom otto with canopy cat rescue
and we rescue cats that get stuck up in
trees
[Music]
cats get stuck in trees a lot we've been
rescuing since about 2008
i'm kidding you would probably do more
cat rescues than anybody in the world
we range from about 375 to 400 rescues
every year it's okay there's a lot of
people that can't afford to pay your
normal arborist five six seven hundred
dollars to rescue a cat
both tom and i really love cats
he's a total sweetie ginger boy we'll
come out and rescue somebody's cat for
free sweetest
all right
canopy cat rescue this is shawn yeah
it's our cat he's climbed up and she's
been up there for three or four
this hours well i think we'll be there
in about 45 minutes or so
climbing trees is inherently risky
our average tree height is 100 feet
sometimes they're a lot taller we start
obsess out how the cat's doing as we're
getting close hi
and then hopefully we can proceed with
the rescue
[Music]
we gotta go in a sack how does that
sound
[Music]
the look that we get from the cat owners
face when we hand them their cat back
is just this overwhelming sense of
relief
are you happy to have him back he's
i know you have no idea
we love doing this and we're gonna do it
for as long as we can you said you got a
cat stuck in a tree
we don't really consider ourselves
heroes but we do like to think of
ourselves as just two guys that are out
there restoring the faith in humanity
[Music]
you can't really call me a crazy cat
lady i'm i'm obsessive i would rather
have 800 cats than another man i don't
need a man in my life
been there done that bought the t-shirt
new get it get it get it get it lord
come on
this is called the cat house on the
kings
it's a 12 acre no cage no kill sanctuary
rescue adoption center and we also do a
lot of spays and neuters
oh come here cricket
[Music]
we have close to 800 adults and 300
kittens on the property as we speak
it wasn't like i planned hey i think
i'll have a thousand cats
what a novel idea it wasn't like that i
thought well there's always room for
more they're gonna kill this one we have
way too many cats
[Music]
so this this was my house
you can see that it's an extremely large
house
so you had to give up your home for
these cats
i tried for about 16 years to make it
work but it wasn't okay having
60-something in my bedroom one night
they threw up in my ear
and that was when i moved all 4 200
square feet is theirs that's why we call
it the cat house
we have saved over 28 000 cats
in 24 years
we have
a staff now of about 45. you have to be
very on top of the job
because
you have a lot of cats that you're
responsible for
no point in rescuing them and taking
them in if you can't take care of them
you know this is not normal
people after a while would say well you
know i think i've done this enough i
think i'll go have a life now i think
i'll go travel nope not me
daphne look this way
yeah
come on i want you to be on tv
[Music]
the trick is trying to think
like a cat
it's one thing to think what would it be
like if i were a cat it's another thing
to try to figure out well what is it
like for a cat to be a cat
so i have different ways of creating
her kind of sounds
um david thai um
classical musician mostly by trade
played the cello in the national
symphony and i came up with the idea of
writing music for cats
here are my bird songs for study
and i slow them down
cats are not very vocal and not
particularly social
the ultimate goal is to be able to
communicate
in something like their language
what other sounds are there that you
know cats would enjoy most of the brain
development of a cat happens outside the
womb i thought the sound of suckling
is a reward related sound that all cats
will have heard as their brains were
forming this swishing kind of sh
sound
yeah i would totally use that could i
name that after your jacket
that's my louis w
swish
another
example of a sound is purring
when you play this music how does a cat
react exactly there are things like uh
they would rub up against the speakers
it shows kind of ownership
and but showing just attention
and it tends to be more comforting to
those cats who have had something of a
hard life
is that cats who need more comfort
are more comforted by it do you have a
cat
no no i actually don't i'm allergic to
cats
you're allergic to cats
[Music]
fake talking cat just what we need
around here salem from sabrina the
teenage witch graced our screens in the
90s salem guard my door so jenny doesn't
go anywhere okay hey dog's guard cat's
watch
and judge for the actor behind the sass
playing the role of a puppet suited him
just fine puppets can get away with
murder don't ever do a scene with him no
one's looking at you
oh
i'm having a bad fur day hi i'm nick
makai and i'm best known probably is the
voice of salem the talking cat on
sabrina the teenage witch hit it cat
i've got no defense salem was a very
frustrated guy i tried to take over the
world his punishment was they turned him
into a cat for a hundred years there was
a lovely bitterness to the character
that i leaned into hard salem
you're the only one who understands me
yeah but it doesn't mean i care you know
i was in the writers room on that show
too so i could pitch my own jokes maybe
i should take your temperature under the
tongue under the
tongue all right i'll check in a few
minutes
i was on set doing the voice live first
four years took a village to do that cat
because then you had animal trainers and
a multitude of live cats
and there was a remarkable crew of
puppeteers our head puppeteer was tom
found it was really gifted he ran the
mouth and we had maury who worked the
body and she spent her days in darkness
jammed into that kitchen island counter
you know just working that body it was a
real team effort
but nick is more than just a cat voice
it was also the voice of norbert don't
mess with the bull my friend you'll get
the horns the big older brother on the
nickelodeon cartoon angry beavers i've
been a writer producer on a bunch of
other shows by king of queens i also
wrote the paul bart mall cop movies with
my pal kevin james
you're a nasty old man
and he's been in front of the camera too
on some well-known shows like seinfeld
[Music]
that 70s show
and this aol ad thanks to america online
i'm really just goofing off
this is back during my trying to make my
career as an actor phase you did some
deep dig there huh
so looks like it's just you and me
want to do each other's hair
[Music]
i love cats i've had cats my whole life
up until very recently we had a cat
named salem a little black cat who we
rescued for 16 years
i tried to make friends with my namesake
wasn't in the car so i hated my gods
[Music]
in southern pennsylvania there is a
battlefield a battlefield so important
that it is thought to be the turning
point of the american civil war
this is a story about that place
it's also a story about cats
thousands and thousands of little cats
this is rebecca hi i'm rebecca and this
is her twin sister ruth hi i'm ruth and
we run a museum of dioramas that are
made with handmade civil war cats
civil
war
cats the combination of a childhood love
for clay cats and a strong fascination
with the american civil war it started
out as a hobby that we just did
as kids putzing around in our bedrooms
that bit of child's play led to a
full-fledged museum which opened in
2013.
[Music]
the two of us discussed how much do we
want to emphasize the cat thing because
we don't want to come off as cutesy cats
the idea is the stories of the men not
so much the fact that they're cats
they're just our cats because
they're cats
incredibly each of these scenes is to
scale one eighth of an inch equals one
foot in cat feet and so each one of our
soldiers represents one soldier who
would have been on the field we'll
calculate the numbers that would have
been left in the regiment and we'll fill
it in with that many cats soldiers so
for example low around top we're going
to eventually have about 5 000 soldiers
on it typically one like the angle we
figure took us about four and a half
years the little round top diorama we
figure is more of a five or six year
diorama
we really just want to make the civil
war more approachable i guess for people
so they can relate to the history and
have more of a connection with the men
and the women involved now that the word
of this cat museum is out all the people
who love cats come in and now not only
are they seeing our dioramas of falling
in love with the five and a half
thousand little furry smiles smiling at
them
but they're also learning the stories
and suddenly they have an appreciation
of gettysburg and the history just
because they came to see the cats
you